رغم الظروف الامنيه التي تعيشها مدينته
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا يتوجه اليا كل صباح
الى منطقه شبيكنزكيا المغلقه بسبب تعرضها
للقصف مخاطرا بحياته في سبيل المساهمه في
اجلاء السكان يقول ان واقع الحرب دفعه نحو
هذا الخيار تطوعي في وقت اصبحت فيه نيران
الحرب تطال يوميا اراضي روسيا
اغلب سكان المدينه غادروها ونساعد من يرغب
في المغادره الى الوضع الانساني هناك صعب
للغايه ما دفعني للمخاطره تطوعا بعد ان
اجليت عائلته الحرب اصبحت تدور على
اراضينا وعلينا العمل معا للتقليل من
تداعياتها
السلطات الروسيه اغلقت المنطقه ولا تسمح
لغير حاملي هويتها بالعبور
رافقنا المتطوع ايليا الى اخر حاجز امني
قبل مدينه شبيكنو
تقدر السلطات ان قرابه عشرين الفا نزحوا
من المنطقه منذ بدايه التصعيد الاخير امام
هذا المركز الاغاثي تصطف يوميا طوابير من
النازحين للحصول على المساعدات تؤكد اداره
انها نجحت في احتواء الازمه
على النازحين كل ما يلزمهم من مساعدات امس
مثلا حصل اكثر من 4000 شخص على معاناه
غذائيه وملابس ومستلزمات اخرى عبئنا كل
الامكانات للعمل ما دامت هناك حاجه لذلك
تعترض الدفاعات الروسيه كل يوم هجمات جويه
في سماء بيلغراد المدينه تعيش هدوءا حذرا
يغيب الاستقرار وتغيب معه اي بوادر على
تغير ميداني وشيك
يسهم في الدفع بخط الجبهه بعيدا عن حدود
المقاطعه كما يامل سكانها حيثما
ذهبت في شوارع مدينه بيلجروت تقابلك هذه
العباره ملجا تقول السلطات المقاطعه ان
الوضع صعب لكنه تحت السيطره الحياه هنا
تتكيف مع واقع جديد في هذه الحرب واقع
مختلف
ومفتوح على كثير من الاحتمالات